you guys may have heard about this big
Comcast Time Warner merger they have
joined evil forces it's a basically
comcast bought time water for 45 billion
dollars that's billion with a B and
comcast is known as one of the biggest
spenders in all of politics they have
over a hundred lobbyists in in DC and I
love this so there was a big
congressional committee on the merger
and you're not going to believe this but
comcast has donated money to all 18
members of that said committee let's
look at some of the donations Senator
Durbin from Illinois 54,000 from comcast
which is the most of any senator on the
committee orrin Hatch got 45,000 Lahey
up in Vermont 52 Mike Lee 17 Al Franken
5,000 Al Franken also is the only one to
oppose the merger and interestingly he
got the least amount of money can you
believe that I find that hard to believe
we've got video of Al Franken talking
about the merger let's go to that I
think comcast does give money to people
who support them that's not necessarily
to buy their support but yeah I really
don't like the role of money in politics
and I think it's just gotten worse and
worse and worse i think citizens united
was a very disturbing a pernicious
ruling I think this latest McCutchen
rule ruling was was awful I you know
it's just giving more power to those who
have have money you know myself you're
like that pernicious I've heard it's a
funny word somebody would so just to
clarify in case you weren't listening to
mr. Franken the guy who's getting the
least amount of money is the only one
fighting it but he does want you to know
that it's not about the money uh is that
release just is that the sad part here
before we get to the merger that the one
guy who's fighting it is getting the
least but yet even he even goes on
television to say it's not that they've
been bought off even though we know that
I
I don't I think is right I think we look
at it too he-he's points bigger the
money in politics is the problem they're
going to be people who oppose this
merger at like I'm gonna make stuff up
here Viacom say and they give a ton of
money too right so at some point issues
like this you get money from both sides
so you're you're probably free to vote
your conscience the problem is that
whether Viacom opposes it or or comcast
fights for it nobody in there is
fighting for consume yeah well whether
this merger happens or not it's not like
this mergers deny it's not a great
victory for the American consumer like
we're sort of screwed either way which I
little victory right because then
hopefully there's some more competition
and prices but I mean we've lost there
is so there is basically so wave our big
debate is whether there are four giant
multimedia companies running everything
or five or three like it's a problem
either way and let's be honest unless
you're me five thousand dollars is not a
lot of money so that I think that that
should just be taken off the table to
begin with who gives a [ __ ] so five
thousand dollar so we should give al
franken extra credit man because there's
nothing any anything to do with that
yeah I mean why would it were five
thousand dollar is the 50,000 a lot
because so dick Durbin who got the most
50,000 in the course of a campaign and
all that is actually nothing to so is
that enough to buy a car it gets a
question find that or so I mean I
presume like I don't know who else is
fighting this but I guess the way did
that some airlines fight mergers of
other airlines cuz it'll be create too
much competition for them I was probably
right that if I can't even up cuz that a
family thing is that a thing but but I
imagine that they don't CBS so so I
imagine that they don't that they don't
want this and I imagine that that the
other that you know AT&T u-verse or
fries and files they don't they might
not want this but everyone's too afraid
to say anything like all of these huge
companies that are gigantic corporations
are totally unwilling to fight this
right so why is that they're huge
companies too yeah I read that i'm
curious whether the big companies are
unwilling to fight it or certainly the
the a mom-and-pop the rectum obama
copyin dollar companies yeah but right
the minute cuz this
that a marriage of what the one in two
biggest mobile providers in the one and
three biggest broadband providers but
you know then the the the content
providers of the people who are could
also be screwed by this as they could
price fix yeah for how much they pay for
each networks programs but they don't
want to fight it because they don't want
to be in a disadvantageous position I
suspect that in some sense the only
people capable fighting this are other
media giants like mean great like
where's Fox when you need them to step
in and fight this I can't believe I'm
like I wish Rupert Murdoch would been
invited me like always right or maybe
that yeah yeah or maybe Google could
design a 20 fiber I was on somebody it's
it matters these but but it sounds like
you when I'll Franken is the lone voice
it sounds like you know when you have
support from orrin hatch and dick Durbin
it's a reminder that sometimes on big
issues like this the parties don't
matter yeah well what's going on in
Minnesota you know Minnesota gave us the
one independent governor we've had Jesse
Ventura and they've given us Al Franken
who's basically an independent for all
intensive purposes what's going on up
there that you can get a place that
gives us michelle bachman also gives us
these independent two words cheese curds
they do they tell you they make people
acting ridiculous way yeah I thought
you're gonna go with ice fishing yeah
you're watching fargo what the hell's
going on so far the last night how I
majburi okay we have a lot of fun really
well done I mean oh you know michelle
bachman in a very specific district
franken by the way I mean he is show
some independence but he's a Democrat ya
know he's a and Jesse Ventura remember
at some interesting fun things but he
lives in Mexico off the grid he's off
the grid yeah so I'm doing it next week
it's called the grid yes yeah and what
about the anti Reach is done with the
antitrust situation to eat does that
just no that's not a thing anymore
nobody cares well it reminds me of money
in politics we used to we talked about
it he rolled yeah but politicians used
to talk about money apologize there was
something called the mccain-feingold
bill God you know like nobody talks
about it so I think we don't care any no
William Howard Taft is attempting to
roll over is great but it can't
cuz there's so many time order cables
like going that was the dead was a dead
fetch well I doubt that Joe I took a
sound factor can I turn it into a cable
yeah that [ __ ] that it up well Benny
might have something to do with a former
FCC Chairman who is now comcast senior
vice president maybe that is something
to do with why things can happen maybe
it's because comcast CEO Brian Roberts
played golf with Obama I don't know if
any of these things are connected so
final thought on this uh is this just
going to make it so that we're just
going to consistently see worse and
worse service I mean that's ultimately
what the concern is that our internet is
just gonna keep getting slower or it's
going to be throttled so that they'll
throttle Netflix if they're not in
partnership with Netflix is you're
saying yeah yeah I mean everybody wants
the same thing everybody wants the most
they can get for the little the littlest
they have to put into it and that's what
the cable companies want they want to
get the most from us by having to do the
least so and they have way more money
and power and stuff than we have so yeah
of course I already see it I'm a verizon
fios customer and for some time and with
files and with one other Netflix was
slow down it was so I mean I watch house
of cards season two and I watched it you
know in the things you have to put up
with it took you 49 minutes instead of
46 oh no it took me forty six minutes
but it was a perfect HD quality better
you worry getting ten yeah right you're
on 720 no I yeah I was in 720 at most
and sometimes would be like a little
blurry Wow yeah I mean Jesus it's like
sorry for your loss you know this is uh
yeah i mean i granted like my daughter's
not hungry right but it's like the same
thing we have 10 fingers 10 toes she has
ten fingers ten little fingers in
tunnels ok she does yeah please send all
your condolences to at ben make 77 on
the twitter that's a big deal real quick
i know we got to go but it's a big deal
not my netflix problem but as you
mentioned when when they're just gonna
start there's gonna be most favored
nation status and and i just don't see
any way that anyone standing up to make
that stop yeah except for people like
those before right so by the way if
you're just if you're a young turks fan
in general we are on YouTube here so we
are the type of company that could be
affected by that because the big boys
could get in bed with other online
things and be like oh the Young Turks
they're actually telling the truth we're
going to slow down their videos so
that's why this stuff is all important